there's been a lot of talk about the
geopolitical impact of the tensions in
the Middle East between Iran in the
United States but of course there's also
a real human angle at all of this and
that is really encapsulated by Nazanin
to Gharib a cliff the British Iranian
woman who's been imprisoned in Iran
since 2016 and many people are worried
that her situation will only become more
dangerous because of the ongoing rising
tensions we're joined now by her husband
Richard thank you so much for being on
the show with you your wife's been in
jail for four years now which is pretty
sobering and how is she yeah I mean okay
in in you know if perspective yesterday
she was was flat worried but probably
less so than the week before which had
been just after missile attacks and
there was a real panic running through
the ward and yesterday there was huge
sadness for her but also for everyone
that lost their lives from the plane
being brought down and you're right
we've been in prison now for nearly four
years and that takes a huge toll and
it's four years that she's been held
essentially as hostage and we've tried
different things
ranting the government being nice that
the government calling and writing nice
- the main authorities and and none of
that's got anywhere and and over time
that makes things fragile and volatile
and and there all sorts of health
dynamics that come with it recently she
was in last week was taken in the middle
of the night to see and the prison
clinic because she'd have an irregular
heartbeat was put on beta blockers just
to calm down panic attacks that she's
getting and and she's one of a number of
British nationals and foreign nationals
who are being held by the Iranian
authorities who were being held as
bargaining chips in different forms and
different leverage and which makes us in
the middle of all this very very fragile
very vulnerable and there's probably a
worry of a really simple in the selfish
level of gosh what does this mean for
our cases all these wider things play
out and will she ever go home yeah will
she ever get home another Christmas that
she's missed and this week your daughter
had the first day at school yes a
milestone that many mothers will always
remember yes no that's right and and
that was lovely
that she is big enough to go to school I
was very proud and took photographs of
her in that ice cream phone once you've
got Daddy enough you know and then went
and bless a blessed you know like
getting had a bladder bursts only get to
tell what actually happened at school
and explained that she'd had sausages
for lunch and they'd had cake actually
learning which bit harder had to talk to
the teacher to find out but yes she came
home in the first reading book and so so
lovely that life goes on for us and for
those who followed our story for a long
long time Gabriela was was kept in wrong
and we only got clearance to bring her
back in November so for a long time I've
been as almost like a semi-permanent
campaigner just maintaining job um cover
bachelor pad and and actually now to
have lots of pink and toys and there's a
real life free emerging in their family
home has been lovely but but in some
ways quite hard for has I mean that our
lives are moving on she wasn't there for
her first day at school she wasn't there
for this Christmas that we've just
passed and she stuck feeling this sort
of that they're kind of impermanence of
time that it just nothing lives well
we've seen of course and the escalating
tensions between the u.s. and Iran and
of course now the arrest of the UK
ambassador to Iran how worried are you
that this could impact on Nazneen
situation yeah like I think it was a
really worrying development um and I was
quite clear in the media last week that
one of the things we're always pushing
for is the rule of law around and Iran
upholds international law and when you
start to play fast and loose with
international norms as the Americans
Jenny we're doing that has consequences
and equally the fact that there's been
this huge legitimate outpouring of grief
and sadness and anger at how could this
plane have been brought down by ordinary
nians and the rest of the ambassador and
the attempt to try and turn that into
this is a foreign plot it's the British
organizing the the protest which is what
so the Iranian Press TV has put out it's
a really bad sign for us because what it
means again is that here they're trying
to build a narrative of it's a foreign
plot and we're besieged and of course we
are in the middle of all that because
Nazneen has regularly brought out as
someone that was involved in
overthrowing the regime and and all
those fake stories that were circulating
and I mean I'm glad the ambassador's out
to give him an insight as to a little
bit of what nothing they've been through
and but as a sign of where things are
going the fact that the regime's
instinct is is paid to deny bad stuff
and then be to blame the foreigners it's
not great if you are a foreigner this
bin blank do
she could be held longer so I think I
think where we are and where we've been
for quite a long time is her sentence is
running and there's that second court
case that was opened and I think if we
get the end of her first sentence they
will just add a second sentence at the
end so yes the longer we don't get out
the more likely we are to have many more
years to pee now you've asked for a
meeting with Boris Johnson who of course
got into trouble for wrongly saying that
Nazarene was teaching when she was over
there he's apologized and retracted it
but still it's something that the
Iranians said seized hold of has he
granted your request for a meeting yet
yes so that's right we've been pushing
for a meeting for a long time and I've
not yet got a firm date but I've got an
understand it's not next week with a
week after so so we're pretty close to
it I think it will be really important
and it doesn't have to be a meeting just
for a family it can be for all of the
families of those who've got people held
and there are a number of us and just
for him to signal that this is a
priority that he's protecting British
citizens that actually ordinary people's
lives matter in this situation there's
the big picture stuff but but there's
also the real people in this kind of
context it's it's you're really easy we
all get wrapped up in geopolitics the
signalling of the Prime Minister that he
has personally taking interest matters
we spoke to you and I don't necessarily
the Security Minister and asked him you
know what reassurances he can give you
and and he were just talking more
generally I suppose about how the
government's working very hard to try
and secure the release of nothing is
there anything the government can do
yeah well I mean I'm sure that's right
that he can't give any reassurances
because it's a tricky situation and the
reality of course is her situation and
others is is you know we are being held
as a hostage
bugling ships there is clear I'm
signaling as to what they would want the
government had to work through what it
does but but it you know we've always
been linked to an old debt that the UK
owes Iran it's not the most obvious time
to be handing over
loads of money to the Iranian
authorities in the middle of what our
real tensions but but that is a
festering soul that due to the way in
which the Prime Minister scrambled
following them his comments and we got
cemented - and a link was made and due
to that actually
unless a resolution was found it's gonna
get very hard for us to get home anytime
soon and just finally you were talking a
little bit earlier interview about the
u.s. actions not always following the
the rule of law do you think the actions
of Donald Trump have made things safer
or less things I think I think the
actions Donald Trump remains much more
volatile and shaking things up certainly
they have changed things an awful lot
and we wearing the middle any plea deal
we're now not tweet we were taken prior
to Donald Trump me he can't that can't
be named later his door certainly his
administration has got Americans home
whereas the UK hasn't succeeded so he's
done some good things he's done some
things that have amazing spectacle
fragile certainly the American families
the British bad news the French Romans
are looking with great concern over the
last week because yeah things have got
much more volatile and much more scary
and thank you so much for coming on
today it's such an important voice for
us to hear in the midst of you know the
wider geopolitical situation and you
know we really do have a best wishes for
you in your families but really thank
you